endolori les apprentis sorciers sont à
la fête plus de 500 fans de la saga
présents pour célébrer la 20e année du
plus ancien site internet francophones
autour d'harry potter
on raconte l'actualité du monde d'harry
potter des animaux fantastiques les
nouvelles sorties de livres de films les
produits dérivés les parcs mais aussi on
va un peu plus loin on fait des articles
qui analysent l'univers qui le décrivent
qui décortique me dire qu on est parvenu
à rester jusque jusqu'aujourd'hui qu'on
a continué à vivre que le fandom harry
potter est toujours là et que la gazette
est toujours là c'est juste magique
d'une journée en immersion à l'orangerie
du château de thoiry au coeur de
l'univers de la magie
c'est un moyen de s'échapper un peu de
s'imaginer dans le monde
dans un autre monde où la sorcellerie et
est intégré à la vie et et voilà ça nous
permet de rêver aussi
on peut partager des anecdotes des
choses qu'on a lu récemment parce que
l'univers est vaste éventuellement je
vais s'amuser à chercher les
incohérences et puis essayer de se
chercher qui connaît mieux tel ou tel
sujet entre deux conférences étaient
organisés également des rencontres de
quidditch le sport du sorcier et des
duels de sortilèges cd principe assez
simple embardée livre on regarde comment
les gens meurent et on essaye de
prévenir ça donc quelques mouvements des
skis et puis derrière on apprend les
mouvements basiques de baguettes une
journée dans un autre monde pour les
fans à conserver précieusement dans une
piscine